mit autos für bücher werben ist eher
ungewöhnlich
martina bolliger nutzt den kleinwagen
als büchertisch vier wochen kostenlos
fahren kann man gewinnen
so hoffen wir dass wir viele bücher
verkaufen und wenn sie der anordnung für
mich interessiert kann er zudem händler
hingehen so dass die bühnensituation ist
in ihrem buchladen legt sie großen wert
auf beratung
viele die vorbeikommen sind stammkunden
sie hat ihre kinderbuchabteilung gerade
vergrößert beschäftigt sieben
mitarbeiter
doch ohne online shop geht auch bei ihr
nichts mehr
kunden können bücher über ihre homepage
bestellen und kostenlos liefern lassen
sie muss das machen um mit dem
online-handel mithalten zu können
wenn ich das nicht mal macht jemand
anders und den umsatz in brauche ich
einfach noch um bestehen zu können
ganz ehrlich gesagt also ich mag das
nicht so sehr weil ich natürlich lieber
die kunden im laden habe weil ich es
liebe die kunden im laden sagen und mit
denen zu kommunizieren
aber ich komme leider nicht drin vor bei
veranstaltungen mit kaffee und selbst
gebackenen kuchen
martina bollinger muss sich immer wieder
was neues einfallen lassen deswegen
kommen ihre kunden und sie lockt sie
auch mit bekannten schriftstellern
die aus ihren büchern lesen
also die ingrid noll kommt jetzt sehr
bald da weil ich da hingehe und dann
kommt noch einer den lang einigen
märkten sergio wenn wir so ein spanier
wird sie auch sehr interessant an
auch in einer kleinen fachwerkstatt wie
oberursel steigen immer mehr kunden auf
elektronische bücher um
der grund für den deutschsprachigen
buchhandel ein eigenes e book lesegerät
herauszubringen
die zahlen zeigen den erfolg dass der
reader des buchhandels torino in
eineinhalb jahren bereits den kindle von
amazon überrundet hat das heißt er hat
einen marktanteil zur zeit von 45
prozent
und kindle hat nur 39 das lesegerät gibt
es auch bei martina bollinger im laden
kunden können ebooks direkt über ihre
homepage herunterladen
gegen die konkurrenz aus dem internet
fühlt sie sich so gut gewappnet